pierre brûlée fait partie de ceux qui
ont choisi d'effectuer un retour au
travail 7 ans après sa retraite j'avais
le goût de retourner aux sources puis de
pouvoir travailler avec des gens
ça fait maintenant 9 mois qu'il
travaille à temps partiel comme serveur
à l'hôtel Le Germain à Montréal moi
quand il y a des gens dans les horaires
sont peut-être pas aussi flexibles le
mien bah là moi j'accepte avec plaisir
de remplacer une flexibilité qui plaît
grandement à son employeur le fait
d'avoir des personnes qui veulent
devenir un peu dans le dans le monde du
travail nous permet aussi de leur donner
ce qu'ils veulent c'est à dire peut-être
un peu plus d'apport social ou d'être au
moins un peu plus actif et en même temps
ça nous donne une expertise pour nos
jeunes employés alors que la plupart des
observateurs s'attendaient à une baisse
ou à un ralentissement marqué de
l'emploi en 2023 il s'en est créé 150
000 en janvier au Canada dont 47 000 au
Québec
c'est dix fois plus que prévu là on va
avoir aussi le budget selon une Abraham
de l'Institut du Québec les employeurs
doivent recruter davantage entre autres
pour pallier le taux d'absentéisme
anormalement élevé de leurs employés
l'absentéisme est plus et 19% plus élevé
aujourd'hui qu'avant la pandémie cette
croissance de l'emploi plus forte
quantité pourrait entraîner une hausse
des salaires on a à la fois des
travailleurs qui vont aller négocier des
salaires plus élevés parce qu'ils disent
l'inflation aujourd'hui elle est élevée
et de fil en aiguille une augmentation
des dépenses dans l’économie et des prix
à la consommation ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal